Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters. Welcome to session seven at a new look for cancer. We've been talking about suppressor systems
Normal program cell death is one suppressor system. That is how your body deals with the damage cell of any kind if it's been the damage has been
As a band of the DNA and the replication phase the cells should go under
Apoptosis simply because of that so that is a protective measure. So
your apoptonic cycle has to do with just cleaning up older cells so that
The mother cell as it reproduces is cleaned up and gotten rid of it causes the cell to basically implode and then your immune system helps carry that away
and destroy any living pieces to it. Also, your cell has a membrane around it. That's a phospholipid bilayer. Any of that membrane are certain proteins that act as
Receptors. So if you want to think of them as a lock and the key is something that attaches to that receptor that turns that receptor
on or turns that receptor off. So that turning on of the receptor actually is a chemical process that changes the
Shape of the protein inside the cell and it turns on a mechanism per se just like you opened up the door and
with the key and it turned on a mechanism that
That began a process within the cell cytoplasm. Today we're going to talk about estrogen beta
Receptors and estrogen receptors inside the cell that affect different cancers. We showed you this picture last week.
That is very complicated. That is a schematic of a cell membrane. It's receptors on that orange part of the
picture here the nucleus in the middle and just this is actually an abbreviation of the different cell intercellular
processes that take place within the cell. We want to talk about what happens from a cellular
membrane perspective today. So here's some pictures of some different cell membranes. So on the right hand side here
this is looking at how a cell divides. There's actually a receptor on the cell
membrane that can stimulate cell division. So if that receptor is greater expressed, if there's a greater
Expression of that receptor, which we're going to see in her two positive cancers, then it's going to stimulate a more rapid
replication of that cell, which with cancer that's not what we want to happen. So it can be a receptor
abnormality. So there's a greater expression of receptors on that cell membrane for some reason, which we'll talk about.
And with that greater expression of those receptors, there's a greater chance of them being stimulated
and then there's whatever that receptor does, it will stimulate that process within the cell.
So if I have more growth factor receptors on the cell membrane, the chance of them being stimulated increases
and the chance of the cell replicating or rapidly increases. So on the bottom picture, on the little bit on the left
is a normal cell. This picture shows two of the replication receptors and this is what's different
with the cancer cell. It has all those different receptors expressed on the cell membrane.
So the chance of them being turned on goes up. So different receptor sight abnormalities, there's what's called a
crass pathway that can be up-regulated, that means it can be increased and will increase cellular proliferation.
So that's what can lead to a tastasis and further growth of the cancer.
So again, summarize if you have an increase amount of receptors that stimulate proliferation of a cell on the cell membrane,
that it's going to stimulate that cell replication. So how do we get those?
So here's what's called her too positive. Estrogen receptor positive cancers have...
Normally you have these different receptors that stimulate down to the nucleus if you look at that picture on the cell replication of that nucleus.
If I have an abnormality, then expressing if I have a breast cancer that expresses her too positive.
Receptor sites, this is what that cancer looks like. So the cancer cells have all these different receptors on the cell membrane.
So the chance of the cancer being more aggressive is higher. Is that bad? Is that good?
Well, if you talk to an oncologist they would probably rather have a person with estrogen receptor positive cancer because there are some medications out there that have been developed for this.
So just in summary again, estrogen then binds to that receptor because that is a stimulus in the replication cycle, binds to that receptor and causes that...
that breast kids are cell to replicate. So the cells divide because you have too much her to receptors on the cell membrane, causes rapid cell division.
And the reason why an oncologist would rather see her to positive cancer versus a triple negative cancer is because of the fact that there's been some medication developed to help remove the signaling process.
So there's a couple different medications in this process. What is to bind to the cells to decrease the availability of the her to receptors?
And what is to box if in which helps remove the estrogens that attach to those receptors? Do they work? Well, yes and no, there's big trials about them.
So I want to talk about some natural ways to deal with her to positive breast cancers and uterine variant cancers here.
First thing I want to talk about is soy. So most of you have heard that soy is really bad because it breaks down to estrogens. Well, that's true, but it's not the whole story.
So fermented soy and the specific products of soy are actually really good for breast cancer, especially for estrogen positive breast cancers because they have the ability to displace the estrogen in those receptor sites.
So what happens with her to positive breast cancer is that the overexpression of the receptors is one thing, but you go back to why do we have an overexpression of those receptors? So there's some controversy with that.
Many of the theories surround an overexpression of what are called zero estrogens in our body. So normally bed and women have estrogen, progesterone and testosterone in their body.
Women have a greater concentration of estrogen and progesterone, they goodness. So estrogen and progesterone act on the cell.
So membranes, they do all sorts of things. They act as stimulators on different cellular processes. They act as gross stimulators on cells as well. So that's good, right? Yes, it is.
The problem is that we have bad estrogens too. So the good estrogens, let's just summarize it as two hydroxy estrogen. So two hydroxy estrogen is an estrogen in our body and then we have another estrogen that would be a bad estrogen, which would be 16 hydroxy estrogen.
Now there's about 30 some different estrogens, so I'm summarizing this. So let's just summarize it as good estrogen, which is normally made by the woman's ovaries and adrenal glands and bad estrogens, which come from our environment, which not only women are exposed to, but men are exposed to as well.
So good estrogens are those made by the body, bad estrogens are those found in the environment. So why is that important? Well, if I am exposed to more bad estrogens, that can affect my cells.
One of the things that it could do to my cells, and this is one of the arguments on why we have such an increase in cancer rates, remember from presentation number one, we went from one in 21 Americans in 1971, when we begun this war on cancer to one in 2.5 Americans get cancer now, when we've been working on this battle for 47 years, we're losing the war.
So why? Well, one of the reasons, there's many, but one of the reasons is our over exposure to bad estrogens.
Bad estrogens come from plastics, come from chemicals. There's bad estrogens in pesticides and herbicides in everyday household chemicals.
There's estrogens found in food, there's estrogens fed to livestock. All that gets into our meat, gets into our milk, gets into our cheese, gets into our food supply.
So you cannot be not exposed to bad estrogens. You could live in a bubble, you could be the greatest person in the world, you could never eat anything but organic, you could grow everything in your garden, you are still going to be exposed to bad estrogens.
But these estrogens, from our environment, are called zero estrogens. They're estrogens from our environment, they're not made in our body.
The truth is you can run, but you cannot hide. There is no way that you could get away from this exposure to these bad estrogens.
Well, it's a big deal about it, isn't my liver supposed to deal with bad things that enter my body? Well, your liver is supposed to deal with different chemicals that enter your body.
The problem is that these bad estrogens circulate into your body and they can fool our body to think that they are the real deal.
So what are the things that these bad estrogens do is they stimulate cell reproduction. That's not a good thing, because that leads to cancer.
The other thing, it gets worse, that the increased concentration of these bad estrogens increases the expression of these receptors on the cell membrane.
So the simple exposure of an increase of the estrogens, think of it this way. So think of the cell if we could put it in a cartoon going, wow, there's all these estrogens, we must need more receptors for them.
So your cells are reproducing cells that have this her to positive expression, meaning that they have a greater concentration of estrogen receptors on the cell membrane.
So it's almost like your cells are setting themselves up for rapid replication. Well, it's part of a whole feedback loop of your body.
There's so much estrogen in the system, we must need more receptors for the estrogen. So that is a major theory on how cancer just ends up promoting itself here.
So how are we going to deal with this problem? Number one, we have to decrease our exposure to zero estrogens. I'm not going to get into that in this talk, but there's a whole presentation that affects multiple presentations on this because this is so, so, so important, not just with cancer but with so many other issues that we have.
We could also act just like these drugs, there are some natural foods that will not just decrease the expression of these, these receptor sites, these her to receptor sites, but they will actually dislodge the bad estrogens from these receptor sites.
And then number three, there are some different nutritional products that you could use that will actually grab onto these zero estrogens and help pull them out of the body, and these are absolutely essential.
Probably for everybody should be taking these products. Definitely, if you have any history of breast cancer in your family, and absolutely definitely, if you have any history of estrogen receptor positive breast cancer in your family.
Your children should be taking these products. You need to be key lading zero estrogens out of your body because this receptor abnormality is now an epigenetic defect.
So now you'll give birth to a child that also has the ability to have the same genetic because it's changed by our environment.
It's an epigenetic defect in your cell membranes. You have an increase amount of her to positive receptors. So you're her to positive.
So what is this all to do with soy? Well, fermented soy in some of the soy isolates have the ability to dislodge that bad estrogen from the receptor site.
But we have to be very careful here. It's only the fermented soy in the soy isolates. It's not eating tofu. It's not drinking soy milk.
So my recommendation for everybody. I never recommend soy milk. I never recommend high concentrations of tofu. Well, what are you supposed to do with your vegetarian?
Well, I understand that a vegetarian is going to eat some tofu. But if you could use fermented soy, you're better off. There were some Japanese studies out that looked at studies or was a Korean study, I believe it was.
Women with breast cancer, the incidents of breast cancer, if they had a half a cup of miso soup every day, their incidents of breast cancer were literally completely slashed close to zero.
Because of the effects of the fermented soy dislodging bad estrogens compared to women, same culture who did not eat miso as a staple.
So fermented soy has the ability to operate P53 as well. That's the suppressor gene, remember. So that will even if estrogen attaches to that receptor and stimulates replication, remember we talked about last time, even if that defect takes place, if you have enough P53, you will negate that and that cell will undergo apoptosis.
Also fermented soy increases bracket 1 and bracket 2 gene expression. Remember we talked about with Angelina Jolie, she has a genetic defect with a decreased expression of bracket 1 and bracket 2 gene. That means those are suppressor systems and so with a decreased expression of that, her chance of getting breast cancer is much higher.
So does that mean you should just have your breasts removed? That's what she did. By answer is no, there's ways to increase that expression from a natural perspective. So just because you have that epigenetic defect doesn't mean that you have to take drastic measures.
So soy isoflavones, not soy itself unless it's fermented. That's what we're talking about. So no regular soy, it has to be a fermented soy product or a specific isoflavone.
So what other things increase this? So there's multiple studies about the specific chemical in salary, parsley and figs that is very beneficial to block the signaling pathway of the hereto receptors.
So that's the benefit, another benefit of juicing. So typically we don't juice figs but we juice green salary and spinach and some other things in our juice. So what's our juice space is carrots, apples and salary is our juice space. We add beets, we add parsley to the juice.
So you have a great hereto positive drink blocker. And then also we talk about having to decrease these zero estrogens. So if you don't have those estrogens to stimulate the hereto positive receptors, number one, you're not going to get replication even if you have that on your cell membrane.
So that's what we talk about reducing zero estrogens. But wait a second, you said you can run but you can't unhide. Well that's true. So this is one product that I recommend to everybody who has any history of breast cancer.
It's really a product that every single person should be taking. It's dim. So maybe you've heard of dim. It does wonderful things and grabbing onto and getting rid of zero estrogens in your body.
In fact there's lots of studies on dim and how it affects in blocky cancer and helping prevent cancer in multiple different ways. So on the bottom of this slide you might want to pause it because here's some sources of zero estrogens. So remember what zero estrogens are. These are bad estrogens in our environment.
Artificial scents, air fresher, food additives, preservatives, household cleaners, detergents, car exhaust, indoor toxins, NUD, organic foods, personal care items. So your shampoo, your lotions, perfumes, anything in a plastic bottle.
This is the danger of drinking plastic water out of a plastic bottle. Plastic food wrap, canned foods. There's zero estrogens in soy if it's not fermented. Styrofoam products have a lot of zero estrogens in it.
It provides fertilized pesticides, solvents, lacquers, paints, cleaners. You go, my gosh, that's my entire environment. I'm sitting on a chair that has lacquered arms that has chemicals spewing from the material. I'm sitting on an artificial surface desk.
How am I possibly going to get rid of all the zero estrogens in my body? That's my point exactly. You have to be using a key later and everybody should be out of product with DIM.
So I don't show the products of this slide, maybe I do at the end here, but it's something that everybody should be out of a DIM product.
So ways to rejuice zero estrogens. DIM does a lot of things. It increases the good estrogens. So here's some active estrogens in your body. Estrogen turns to ester dial. And that turns to the two hydroxy ester dial. And these are the good estrogens on the top of this chart.
The bad estrogens are the 16 hydroxy, estrogens are the four hydroxy estrogens. These you could call the bad estrogens. DIM's effect of the bad estrogens is decreasing.
And it increases the expression of the good estrogens. So it dramatically reduces your cancer risk if you are a DIM product. I do show some of these DIM products.
DIM of AL is DIM alone. I think it's 100 milligrams of DIM. The libido stem is another good product that has DIM in it. The broccoli protect, the broccoli protect has the other products of broccoli that help decrease zero estrogens, decrease her to expression.
We don't even talk about, but curcumin has a great affinity to decrease her to expression as well. Covered a lot of this week, if you have to go back on the said of that do so. And I will see you next week.